Tyrion: All hail Bran the
Broken, first of his name.
All: All hail Bran the Broken.
Narrator: It's official,
"Game of Thrones" has ended,
and the character who won it all
was one of the most overlooked
candidates for the crown.
Bran, the youngest Stark, has
no blood claim to the throne,
and he never seemed particularly
interested in ruling.
But if we look back, there were
some clues he'd end up king.
Here are 10 of them, and here's a warning:
Spoilers are coming.
Bran's importance is established
early on in the series.
In fact, he's the first major character
we meet in the pilot.
The first scene in Winterfell centers
on Bran practicing his archery
with the older Starks looking on.
This introduction is
consistent with the novels,
which open with a chapter
written from his point of view.
Did author George R.R. Martin favor Bran
to end up on the throne all along?
It seems likely.
One particular moment in the pilot
seems significant in retrospect.
The camera cuts to young Bran
during Ned Stark's recitation
of the execution oath.
Just as Ned says the line,
"King of the Andals and the First Men."
Ned: In the name of Robert
of the House Baratheon,
the First of His Name...
Jon: Don't look away.
Ned: King of the Andals
and the First Men...
Jon: Father will know if you do.
Narrator: It seems they
left it deliberately unclear
whether we should focus on
Bran or Jon in that shot.
That's a tactic the show often uses
to subvert our expectations.
For example, after Hardhome, it seemed
that the Night King was after Jon,
when in fact it was Bran
that he really wanted.
Based on the Night
King's fixation on Bran,
maybe we should have known
that he was destined for the throne.
As Bran explained before
the Battle of Winterfell,
the Night King's goal
was to erase this world
in its entirety.
To do so, he had to erase Bran first.
In view of the show's ending,
some fans believe the
Night King was dead set
on destroying Bran because he knew
he'd become Westeros' ruler
and a strong, competent ruler at that.
It seems significant that
Bran is also the first person
we see targeted by Jaime Lannister,
the man infamously known as "Kingslayer."
In the finale, when Tyrion
makes his impassioned case
in front of Westeros' leaders,
it's clear he has a strong
appreciation for Bran.
Apparently, it's reciprocated
because Bran makes Tyrion his hand
despite his spotty track
record as Daenerys' adviser.
In the events leading up to this moment,
it might have been easy
to overlook the friendship
between Bran and Tyrion, especially since
they've only interacted a
handful of times on-screen,
but their special bond actually dates back
to the fourth episode of the series.
Following Bran's injury,
Tyrion traveled all the way
to Winterfell, bringing designs
for a customized saddle.
Bran: Will I really be able to ride?
Tyrion: You will.
Robb: Is this some kind of trick?
Why do you want to help him?
Tyrion: I've a tender spot in my heart
for cripples, bastards, and broken things.
Narrator: Tyrion's
words inspired the title
of that episode in season
one, as well as the moniker
of Bran the Broken that he coins later on.
Tyrion and Bran's relationship picks up
right where they left off
in the second episode of season eight.
After the battle-strategy meeting,
everyone leaves the room
except the two of them.
Tyrion pulls up a chair and asks Bran
to recount the story of his travels.
The writer of this episode, Bryan Cogman,
tipped us off to the significance
of the Bran-Tyrion bond
in an interview back in April.
"Tyrion does have a connection
with Bran," he said.
"Tyrion's a student of history
and I think him wanting
to talk to Bran is about
him trying to understand...
Obviously, Bran's had a
very unique experience."
This would explain why later
Tyrion is so ready to vouch
for Bran in light of his
incredible personal journey
to becoming the Three-Eyed Raven.
Tyrion approaches Bran
again two episodes later
at the victory celebration following
the Battle of Winterfell.
He compliments Bran's wheelchair,
saying it's even better
than the saddle he designed
back in season one.
According to Bran, his
chair is based on the one
Daeron Targaryen built for
his nephew 120 years ago.
Based on the timeframe, he
must be referencing Daeron II,
also known as Daeron the Good.
His familiarity with that
history impresses Tyrion,
who told Joffrey back in
season four that Daeron's story
should be required reading
for any future ruler.
Joffrey: A book?
Tyrion: "The Lives of the Four Kings,"
Grand Maester Kaeth's
history of the reigns
of Daeron the Young
Dragon, Baelor the Blessed,
Aegon the Unworthy, and Daeron the Good.
A book every king should read.
Narrator: Tyrion says
Bran's historical knowledge
will serve him well as Lord of Winterfell,
but he's surprised to
learn Bran has no intention
of holding that title.
At this point, it's entirely possible
Bran had already foreseen
himself on the throne,
in which case his
reaction would make sense
on multiple levels.
Bran: I don't really want anymore.
Narrator: If he expected
to be crowned king,
why would he take on a lordship?
In episode six, he does
imply that he'd known
about his destiny beforehand.
As for Daenerys, it's safe to assume
Bran knew her fate well
before the rest of us.
In a vision back in season four,
he saw the shadow of a dragon flying
over the rooftops of King's Landing.
When he was fleeing the cave
with Meera in season six,
that ominous shot recurred
in a longer dream sequence
that also included images of Daenerys
and of a full-grown Drogon in the sky.
These were intercut with shots of Aerys II
and his green wildfire, connecting
the Mad King of the past
with the Mad Queen of the near future.
The question is whether Bran shared
this information with anyone.
Some fans have theorized that
his conversation with Tyrion
in episode four continued
after the camera cut away
and that during that time, Bran warned him
about Daenerys' imminent descent.
It wouldn't be the first
time the Three-Eyed Raven
issued warnings off-screen.
The season seven finale revealed
that Bran had been advising his sisters
about Littlefinger's schemes.
Did he confide similarly in Tyrion?
If so, that would explain the certainty
with which Tyrion spoke to Jaime
about the outcome of the impending battle.
Jamie: It's not impossible
that she'll win.
Tyrion: She won't.
Jamie: If the three dragons are
dead, she's evened the odds.
Tyrion: The city will fall tomorrow.
There won't be an Iron
Fleet for much longer.
Do it!
If you don't, you'll
never see Cersei again.
Narrator: Maybe Tyrion mistakenly thought
he could change the inevitable
by issuing fierce warnings
to all the important players.
Tyrion: Her followers will abandon her
if they know the war is lost.
Give them that chance.
If the city surrenders,
they will ring the bells
and raise the gates, please,
if you hear them ringing the
bells, call off the attack.
Swear to me, escape.
The two of you, together.
Narrator: Bran's detached
attitude toward power
may be the result of foresight,
or it may just reflect
the state of enlightenment
he's reached as the Three-Eyed Raven.
Either way, the show hints
that the kind of indifference
Bran exhibits is actually an asset.
This idea is referenced in
season eight, episode four,
when Tyrion and Varys are
discussing Jon's fitness to rule.
Tyrion: He doesn't want the throne.
Varys: Have you considered the best ruler
might be someone who doesn't want to rule?
Narrator: It's likely
that Varys' observation
made Tyrion think of his exchange
with Bran earlier in that episode.
Perhaps it was at this moment
that the idea was planted
in Tyrion's head that Bran
should be crowned king.
What do you think?
Did the show hint at
Bran's destiny all along,
or did the ending feel out of the blue?
And did we miss any major clues?
Let us know in the comments.